on reparle de la rénovation pédagogique
des lycées françois bayrou le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation tenait une
conférence de presse ce matin
il ne fait pas table rase de la réforme
langue mais il apporte quand même
quelques éléments de simplification une
simplification très attendue par les
lycéens et par les parents d'élèves
il ne s'y retrouvait plus dans les
mesures qui devaient s'appliquer à la
classe de première ce matin françois
bayrou a opté pour davantage de clarté
détails avec lauren cusin ce qui change
la répartition des matières la réforme
langue était confuse aux yeux des
professeurs élèves des parents avec
quatre groupes de matières obligatoires
et optionnelles
certains redoutaient une trop grande
spécialisation des élèves
le système bayrou est plus simple les 30
heures de cours environ seront répartis
en enseignement obligatoire et en option
les matières obligatoires sont à peu
près les mêmes que celles enseignées
jusqu'à présent dans les différentes
séries
à noter qu'en séries littéraires le
latin et le grec peuvent réapparaître
les options l'élève pourra en choisir au
moins 3 contre une ou deux voire parfois
aucune avec la réforme langue ce qui est
maintenu le principe de trois grandes
séries littéraire économique et
scientifique
on garde également les modules ils
permettent aux professeurs de réunir
pendant quelques heures leurs élèves par
petits groupes en français maths langues
histoire géographie en classe de
première les lycéens auront deux heures
de modules par semaine dont une
consacrée aux méthodes de travail
le ministre de l'éducation justifie ses
décisions je pense que le message
premier en tout cas d'une mauvaise mais
je pense qu'on a procédé à marche forcée
et qu'on a voulu créer de l'irréversible
ces mesures devraient satisfaire dans
l'ensemble les enseignants